Sunni Muslims who make up the vast
majority of the Muslim world I believe
90% are Sunni Muslims are named after
the Sunnah and the Sunnah simply the
best English translation would be uh the
example or to emulate. So what does that
mean? you you are following the example
of the greatest man of in the world
Muhammad as he's known amongst Muslims
and in Islam and his example is
contained in the hadith which is volumes
and volumes and volumes of books and
Muslims have their own science of the
hadith whereby they rank the hadith from
strongest to weakest to put it simply
for you let's say there's two hadith
collections bkari and Muslim means
canonical or righteous it's correct okay
so those volumes For example, amongst
Sunni Muslims are believed to be
literal. This is what Muhammad said.
This is what Muhammad did. Therefore,
because we're following the example of
Muhammad, we must follow those words as
well. Okay? So, those in Islam are known
as the twin pillars of Islam. The Quran,
the literal words of Allah and the
hadith where the Sunnah, the example is
derived from the example of Muhammad.
Because Muslims are going to follow the
example of Muhammad. If Muhammad said do
this, then they're going to do it. If
Muhammad without even saying something.
So the the hadith really captures his
words and his deeds. So if there's a
hadith that talks about Muhammad did
something or didn't do something that
too makes its way into the idea of what
Allah wants you to do because this is
his final and greatest of prophets,
Muhammad. Okay? So he's given you the
Quran, Allah's own words, and now he
wants you also to follow the example of
his final prophet, Muhammad. So guess
what else those two things are called?
The Quran and the Hadith. Well, taken
together actually they become what's
called Sharia law. Okay, that is Sharia
law. This is where Sharia Allah is
derived from primarily the Quran and the
hadith but also things like the
consensus of the so if there's a
disagreement there's an ambiguity the
who are the Islamic scholars the sh or
the shakes the shiks the clerics all
right they reach consensus okay so
there's something really ambiguous based
on their consensus so there's a majority
ruling amongst these fellows on some
whatever controversial topic then that
becomes part of Sharia And another sort
of method that's used in Arabic, it's
called alios, which means analogical
reasoning is the best way to put it. So
you find an analogy. So for example, the
Quran and Muhammad never outlawed beer
or vodka. But so does that mean you can
drink beer and vodka literally? Well,
no. Because based on analogy, he did
outlaw wine. And therefore based on
that, why is wine outlawed? Because well
of its alcoholic content and therefore
everything that has alcohol is also
banned. So that also is part of Sharel.
Those four things are the totality of
Sharia Allah. The Quran which is the
word of Allah. The Sunnah which is the
example and deeds of Muhammad the
world's most exemplar man as he's known
in Islam. And these two other minor
techniques essentially which is trying
to find analogical reasoning and the
consensus of the those two are like I
said more methods but the substance is
the Quran and the hadith. Okay. Now that
is what Allah is. Sharia law is derived
from those. Okay. So we talked about the
word Islam. The Islam the great
surrender. Well etmologically connected
to that word Islam is Muslim. Right? And
that is one who has surrendered. Okay.
So what are they surrendering to? I just
got done telling you the will of Allah
as captured in Allah's own verbatim
words in the Quran as well as in Allah's
favorite prophets words and deeds in the
sunnah. And it's all wrapped together
with a nice bow by the and their
consensus and their analogical
reasoning. And that ladies and gentlemen
is Sharia law. So you'll imagine and
you'll understand why I and I'm sure
every Muslim when they hear what I just
read to you from Donald Trump to
Governor Abbott to so many other
politicians and thinkers and talking
heads who have no problem coming up and
praising Islam and welcoming Muslims and
talking about how Islam has a place in
the West. But on the other hand, they
have also have no problem lambasting and
condemning and renouncing the very
concept of Sharia law. As you can see,
there's obviously some cognitive
dissonance going on here in this sort of
contradictory way of thinking. I think
it's called the fallacy of meaningless
distinction or something to that effect
where you actually think there's a
distinction between something when there
really isn't. Bring back the fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.